[موسيقى]
كشف التحقيق الاستقصائي الذي اجرته قناه
الجزيره حول وفاه الزعيم الفلسطيني الراحل
ياسر عرفات ادله وحقائق علميه على وجود
ماده البولونيوم الاشعاعيه في ملابسه
واغراضه الشخصيه ما يثير تساؤلات عده حول
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وفاته
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لكي نناقشه في عنوانين
رئيسين كيف سيسهم كشف الجزيره في تحديد
طبيعه وفاه عرفات وكيف ستؤدي الادله
العلميه الى تحديد الجهه المسؤوله عن
تسميمه
بالبولي
في ضوء التحقيق الذي اجرته قناه الجزيره
حول ملابسات وفاه الرئيس الفلسطيني الراحل
ياسر عرفات طالبت السلطه الفلسطينيه
باجراء تحقيق دولي حول ظروف وفاته على
غرار التحقيق في عمليه اغتيال رفيق
الحريري حيث اظهرت الادله العلميه التي
كشفها التحقيق ان عرفات توفي مسموما بماده
البولونيوم غير المدعم ما يثير تساؤلات
حول الجهه المسؤوله والكيفيه التي وصلت من
خلالها ماده البولونيوم الى
عرفات من منا لم تساوره الشكوك بشان رحيل
الرئيس الرمز مضت ثمانيه اعوام قبل ان
ينكشف جزء هام من الغموض الذي كان يرحل
الى الابد مع ياسر
عرفات شبكه الجزيره حققت
واستقصاء والخبراء الدوليين لفك احجيه
استعصت على الاطباء الفرنسيين الذين
عالجوا ياسر عرفات عام
2004 فحص بعض من متعلقات عرفات وملابسه
فتره مرضه كان كافيا ليبلغ المتخصصون في
معهد الفيزياء الاشعاعيه في لوزان بسويسرا
نتيجه مدويه اثار واضحه لنسبه عاليه من
ماده البولونيوم المشعه
الفتاكه الحقيقه الصادمه الاخرى
البولونيوم غير المدعم عنصر كيميائي ينتج
حصرا في المفاعلات النوويه فمن اين جاء
وكيف وصل الى جسم الرئيس الفلسطيني الراحل
رئيس لجنه تحقيق حركه فتح في قضيه وفاه
عرفات تحدث عن ثغرات كانت في مقر اقامه
الرئيس الفلسطيني الراحل سواء في الطعام
او الادويه او في المبنى نفسه لكن اللجنه
واخرى غيرها تشكلت منذ عام 2004 محل نقد
او اتهام بالتقصي
انه مثلا موقف صائب عريقات عضو اللجنه
التنفيذيه لمنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه الذي
يتساءل لماذا لم تقم تلك اللجان بما قامت
به الجزيره عريقات طالب بتحقيق فلسطيني
جدي حول ملابسات الفتره التي حصر فيها
عرفات وصولا الى لجنه تحقيق دوليه على
غرار تلك التي شكلت في قضيه رفيق الحريري
بالتوازي مع المسار القانوني والاجرائي
يرى الاطباء حاجه لاجراء مزيد من
الاختبارات تحديدا على عظام الراحل
العرفات والتربه المحيطه برفات لا تمانع
سها عرفات ارمله الرئيس الفلسطيني الراحل
من استخراج رفاته بل انها تطلب ذلك للتثبت
من تسميمه
اشعاعيا وليست القياده الفلسطينيه كما
يبدو اقل حرصا على ان يحص حص الحق في هذه
القضيه فقد ابدت استعدادا كاملا للتعاون
بما في ذلك فحص رف الراحل ابو عمار سيتم
ذلك اذا تم على ضوء ما كشفته شبكه الجزيره
التي اجتهدت لاجابه على السؤال الهام ما
الذي قتل الزعيم الفلسطيني لعل الاجابه
ستمهد لاخرى عن سؤال اهم واصعب من
القاتل ولمناقشة
حاتم عبد القادر مسؤول ملف القدس في حركه
فتح ومن عمان الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ياسر
الزعتره اهلا بكم جميعا دكتور سلامه كيف
يمكن نقل البولونيوم اذا اذا كان هنالك
مرء يريد ان يمسك بماده البولونيوم
وينقلها الى مكان معين كيف يتم
ذلك
اي ماده اليورانيوم ماده البولونيوم 200
هي ماده خطيره جدا معدن سام مشع بيصدر
اشعاعات خطيره بتسمى اشعاعات الفا او
جسيمات الفا وتداول
هذا هذا المعدن لا يمكن تداوله بال باليد
ولكن بيحتاج بوشنز واجهزه ومعدات خاصه
لنقله من مكان الى اخر فمش من الس وده
لشده خطوره التعرض الاشعاعي منه فده مش هل
هل يؤدي ايضا حتى ولو لم يكن موجود في اكل
او شراب وتناوله الانسان يعني لو باليد
فقط
لمسه ايضا يتعرض
للالفا هذا
المعدن تعر لا يسبب او البولونيوم لا يسبب
تعرض خارج الجسم لكن اذا دخل داخل الجسم
عن
طريق المص الغذاء او عن طريق الدم او عن
طريق الاستنشاق فانه بيؤدي الى تدمير
جينات الخلايا داخل الجسم وتحويلها الى
خلايا سرطانيه ده في نهايه المطاف فهو
بتاثيره بيكون تاثير داخلي طيب دكتور هذا
تقريبا اصبح معروفا منذ الامس شرحناه
كثيرا على شاشه الجزيره و يعني هناك افاده
من التكرار ولكن سؤالي كان بالتالي في ضوء
ما شرحته لنا وما شرحناه بالامس كيف يمكن
لاي احد ان ان ينقل هذه
الماده الى انسان اخر يعني هل يضعه مثلا
في انبوب
معين هل عليه ان يضع كمامه على وجهه قبل
ان يضعه في الاكل والشراب
مثلا بتنقل بمواسم او ان انا اقول هذه
الماده في تفسيري الشخصي انها ممكن ان
تكون وضعت في نوع من الادويه مماثل
للادويه التي كان يتناولها الرئيس ياسر
عرفات مشابهه له تماما ودست له في كدواء
اتحطت لان لو تتصوري حضرتك ان
نص ان ربع
عشر ا او واحد على مليون من الجرام
من الجرام من البولونيوم
210 ممكن ان يكون كميه قافيه قاتله لاي
انسان فهي هو محتاج
ريسز اذا اذا يكفي
يكفي يكفي دس كميه قليله يعني بعض
الحبيبات الصغيره منه في
حبات
وتاثيره تاثير ايوه التاثير السمي
لهذا للبولونيا اكثر الاف المرات من
سيانيد
ا من سيانيد البوتاسيوم اللي هو بيعتبر من
اخطر المواد
السامه المتعارف عليها كيميائيا فهو من
الناحيه الكيميائيه تاثيره سام بجانب
تاثيره الاشعاعي ام طيب دكتور ايضا في ضو
ماش لنا الان هذا يعني بانه لا يمكن لاي
اي كان ان يتعاطى مع هذه
الماده هنالك محترفون يجب ان يتعاط مع حتى
في زرعها في الاكل او في الدواء و ونشير
ايضا الى ان هذه الماده لا تصنع الا من
قبل مفاعلات نوويه يعني ليس من قبل افراد
وانما من قبل دول اليس
كذلك ايوه بالضبط كده مش من السهل الحصول
عليها من اي مكان غير من مرا مكز بحثيه او
مراكز علميه من من اماكن فيها مفاعلات
نوويه او اجهزه زي اجهزه زي السيكلوترون
والبيت ترون يعني من اماكن من اماكن علميه
او سنترز علميه هي لكن مش من اي مكان ممكن
ان توجد هذه الماده نعم سيد عبد القادر
ضيفي من القدس بناء على هذا الشرح وبناء
الى الث التي اشار اليوم اليها ايضا في
اثناء تحقيقها السيد
التراوي هل اقرب الى سيناريو لو اردنا ان
نرسم سيناريو لكيف دس هذا السم هل الاقرب
هو انه وضع في الادويه مثلا التي كان
ياخذها الزعيم الراحل ياسر
عرفات يعني اولا ست غالت دعيني اتقدم
الشكر لقناه جزيره التي عنك توصلت الى ما
لم تستطع الوصول اليه لجان التحقيق
باتجاه
معرفه وسيله التي استخدمت لاغتيال الرئيس
الشهيد ياسر عرفات بالتاكيد انا اعتقد انه
يعني وسيله اما ان تكون من خلال الادويه
او تكون من خلال المواد الغذائيه التي
ادخلت الى الرئيس ياسر عرفات خاصه في فتره
الحصار معظم الادويه والاغذيه التي عنك
دخلت المقاطعه في فتره الحصار هي كانت
باشراف اسرائيلي ومن الب الاسرائيلي الى
حد كبير ونحن لا نستبعد ان انك يكون
الجانب الاسرائيلي هو الذي هيا وادخل هذه
الماده السوميه البلون يوم 210 الى الدواء
او الغذاء الموجه الى الرئيس ياسر عرفات و
وعننا كما تعلمين يعني الرئيس ياسر عرفط
كان يؤمن بالقضاء والقدر ولم يكن يحتاط
يعني الاحتياطات الامنيه فيما يتعلق
بالادويه او بالغذاء ولذلك نعتقد بانه هذا
دس له في فتره حصار المقاطعه من خلال
الادويه او من خلال المواد الغذائيه وهذا
بالتاكيد ما سوف يكشف عنه التحقيق لانه
الجزيره الان وضعت الاساس التي يمكن
البناء عليه باتجاه معرفه قتله الرئيس
ياسر عفاط سواء من خلال الاداه التي
استخدمت من اجل دسه دسم او الجهه التي اي
يعني يعني يعني الى حد ما قامت بدس لسوم
وهي معروفه بالنسبه لنا الجهه الاسرائيليه
ولكن الان السؤال بعد التاكد من ان رئيس
يسر العرفات قد اغتيل سما فالان تحقيق يجب
ان عنك يدار حول الاداه التي استخدمت من
اجل دس السوم للرئيس ياسر عرفاه وذا
بالتاكيد سوف نتحدث عنه لاحقا سيد
الزعاتره
ام بالامس ارمله الزعيم الراحل ياسر عرفات
السيده سه عرفات عندما س سالناه عن ان
كانت قد تعرضت لضغوط او تهديدات لا تطالب
بتحقيق او بتشريح الجثه فور وفاه زوجها
قالت ليس مباشره ولكنها شعرت بذلك وصلت
اليها رسائل غير مباشره بانها قصه كبيره
لا يمكنها ان تقف بوجهها من الافضل لها ان
يعني تتفادى هكذا مطالبات عندما يجري
ايصال هكذا رسائل سواء مباشره او غير
مباشره الا يعني ان هنالك فعلا جريمه وقعت
ويجري التغطيه
عليها
انا لا اعتقد ان هناك احدا في الشعب
الفلسطيني كانت تساور اي شكوك في ان
الرئيس الفلسطيني ياسر العرفات رحمه الله
قد تعرض لعمليه اغتيال بالسم هذه مساله
كانت بالغه الوضوح المجرم كان معروفا
والمجرم كان يهدد وكان يتحدث عن ذلك بكل
وضوح وصراحه الصحفي الاكثر قربا من شارون
اوردان اصدر كتابا اسمه اسرار شارون عام
2007 وتحدث عن كيف تحلل شارون من التزامه
امام جورج بوش في واشنطن وعندما طالبه
جورج بش بان يترك موت ياسر عرفات لله عز
وجل قال له اننا احيانا يجب ان نساعد الله
بتعبير شارون في ذلك الوقت و وقال انه في
تلك اللحظه شعر شارون انه تحرر من عبئ
ثقيل ال مساله انه المجرم واضحه كل الوضوح
لا احد يستطيع ان لا احد يشك ان شارون هو
المسؤول عن قتل ياسر عرفات لكن هناك اجواء
مهدت لهذه العمليه عمليه القتل هذه
الاجواء وفرتها جهات فلسطينيه وجهات عربيه
وجهات دوليه على الصعيد العربي بالتاكيد
نظام حسني مبارك و بشقيه عمر سليمان وحسني
مبارك كان متورطين في رفع الغطاء عن ياسر
عرفات واعطاء الفرصه لشارون لكي يقتل
توفير البديل في الساحه الفلسطينيه من
خلال المجموعه التي استخدمت امريكيا
واسرائيليه من اجل الانقلاب على ياسر
عرفات هؤلاء هم الذين وفروا الاجواء
لشارون لكي يرتكب الجريمه هؤلاء اغتالوا
عرفات سياسيه قبل اغتياله بالسم هؤلاء
حاولوا الانقلاب عليه عسكريا قبل عام من
مقتله عن طريق محمد دحلان وبالتعاون مع
محمود عباس هذه الاجواء التي صنعتها صنعها
هذا الفريق المناهض للرئيس الفلسطيني هو
هي التي مهدت الاجواء لشارون من اجل ان
يرتكب الجريمه بالتاكيد الاجواء العربيه
كانت حاضره والاجواء الدوليه في ظل سطوه
القوه الامريكيه في عام 2004 كانت حاضره
ايضا وبالتالي الفيلم وفر لنا فكره عن كل
هذه الاجواء سواء الجانب الوحيد الجديد في
كل القصه هو ان هذه الماده على وجه
التحديد هي التي استخدمت في عمليه
الاغتيال وانا استغرب لماذا شكك التحقيق
في اللحظات الاخيره بان العمليه الاغتيال
قد تمت بالسم وك و متعلقات الرئيس
الفلسطيني تشي بذلك بكل وضوح ربما لاسباب
مهنيه او قضائيه فعل فعلوا ذلك لكن الشعب
الفلسطيني مدرك ان المجرم معروف و
والاتهامات التي كانت تتوالى بين الفرقاء
في الساحه الفلسطينيه بدءا باتهام فاروق
القدومي لعباس ودحلان بالتورط في الجريمه
وليس وانتهاء ومرورا باتهام دحلان من قبل
المجلس الثوري واللجنه المركزيه لحركه فتح
بالتورط في اغتيال ياسر عرفات وانتهاء
باتهامات محمد رشيد كل هذه تؤكد ان هناك
تواطؤ لا اقول انا لا اقول على الاطلاق ان
هناك من القياده الفلسطينيه من كان على
علم ربما ان يكون لا انفي لكن لا استطيع
ان اتهم ان هناك احدا في القياده
الفلسطينيه كان يعلم ان شارون في هذه
اللحظه سيقتل ياسر عرفات وبهذه الطريقه او
تلك لكن هناك تواطؤ التواطؤ هو في تمهيد
الا التر عل
عواط ايضا تواطؤ يعتبر تهمه اليوم جبريل
رجوب مثلا ايضا في احد النشرات قال ليس
هذا وقت اتهام الفلسطينيين وتقليم بعض على
بعض ف فليركع الادله وعلى المتهم الحقيقي
في هذا الموضوع اريد ان اسالك عن موقف ا
دختر كان زعيم الشنبات في حين يقول عرفات
كان له اعداء في الداخل والخارج نفى اي
علاقه لاسرائيل بالتسمم ما
رايك هذا كلام فارغ لانه هذه الانواع من
السم لا تتوفر الا في الاتحاد السوفيتي
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه واسرائيل
واسرائيل استقطبت كل خبراء السموم عندما
انهار الاتحاد السوفيتي استقطبت جزء كبير
من هؤلاء الخبراء وهي الوحيده التي تستطيع
ان تفعل ذلك لكن انه عمليه التواطؤ ثم
عمليه التستر على الجريمه الذي تقول سه
عرفات صحيح فرنسا ت ترت على الجريمه نظام
حسني مبارك وعمر سليمان تستر على الجريمه
وزين العابدين بن علي تستر على الجريمه
والفريق الذي ورث ياسر عرفات ومهدت له
الاجواء من اجل وراثه ياسر عرفات في
السلطه وفي المنظمه وفي فتح تستر على
الجريمه
ايضا صحيح لم تقل ذلك صراحه فقط للتوضيح ك
تق على اي حال سناخذ فاصل هي قالت يعني
بالنسبه لفرنسا بالتحديد كانت حريصه على
ان تقول ان فرنسا فعلت كافه ما بوسعها على
اي حال فاصل قصير نتابع بعده النقاش حول
تحقيق الجزيره حول ملابسات وفاه ياسر
عرفات وكيف ستؤدي الحقائق العلميه الى
التي كشفها التحقيق الى تحديد الجهه
[موسيقى]
المسؤوله اهلا بكم من جديد في حلقتنا التي
تتناول تحقيق الجزيره حول ملابسات وفاه
ياسر عرفات وكيف ستؤدي الح قاق العلميه
التي كشفها التحقيق الى تحديد الجهه
المسؤوله دكتور سلامه في حال كما ذكرت في
بدايه الحلقه دس السم في دوائه عبر حبيبات
صغيره صغيره جدا اذا كيف نفسر وصول ماده
البولونيوم الى
ملابسه ا دي طبعا
نتيجه ممكن تكون نتيجه الافرازات في اثناء
مرضه وخروج هذه الافرازات من جسم
الافرازات من جسمه وسببت تلوث في حاجات
لان ممكن ممكن تكون في العرق بتاعه
في الغطاء الراس اللي كان بيلبسه في
ملابسه الداخليه لان بيحصل فيه طبعا
سكريشن
او
خروج ممكن يكون خروج ارادي او لا ارادي من
هذه السوائل من سوائل الجسم
في للملابس
فبتل الملابس يعني دكتور هذه الماده في
حال تجرعها المر عبر غذاء او دواء او ما
شابه يفرز جسمه هذه الماده وبالتالي يمكن
كشفها عبر ملابسه او القبعه على راسه او
فرشاه اسنانه
حتى فعلا لانها بتعمل تدمير لحاجات كتيره
جوه
الجسم تدمير للجينات داخل الجسم لدرجه
ان نتيجه اتلاف الخلايه بتحصل حاجه اسمها
الصدمه السميه للامعاء
نعم ف بينتهي الجسم بتؤدي بعد كده الى فشل
كل الاجهزه الداخليه داخل جسم الانسان نعم
وصولا الى القلب انا اريد ان اسالك للفشل
الكلوي وال
في النهايه حت يصل الفشل الى القلب اريد
ان اسالك
عن بقايا هذه الماده هل يمكن ان تكون ايضا
موجوده في الروفات في العظام بعد ثمان
سنوات فعلا ممكن تكون
لان العمر النصفي للبولونيا
للبل كبير
جدا ا طويل فممكن قوي نلاقي دي هيستمر
نلاقيه
في العظام الموجود ولذلك يعني يستحسن او
يوصى بتحليل رفاه
الجثمان ا هو يفقد يق 210 العمر النصف
بتاعه كبير واللي هو اخطر نظائر
البولونيوم
الموجوده يفقد نصف قيمته مع مرور مده
زمنيه معينه لذلك سالتك انه ثماني سنوات
ليس بالفتره القليله لذلك سالتك ان يبقى
خصوصا في
عظامه ممكن ان توجد في اثار لهذا لعنصر
البولونيوم 210 في في عظام ال
الجثمان سيد عبد القادر ضيفي من
القدس المطالبه بلجنه تحقيق دوليه على
غرار اللجنه التي الت شكلت من اجل معرفه
من قتل رفيق الحريري كيف
سيبدا اليه تنفيذ او تطبيق هذا
المطلب يعني اولا سيد غاده لا يجوز لهذا
الاكتشاف العلمي الكبير لقناه الجزيره ان
يتحول الى اتهامات الوقت ليس وقت اتهامات
وانما الان الوقت جمع ادله بالتاكيد
السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه اعلنت بانها
سوف تتعاون مع اي لجنه تحقيق اي السلطه
وطالبت بلجنه تحقيق دوليه وسوف يتم توجه
الى الامم المتحده من خلال جامعه الدول
العربيه من اجل المطالبه بلجنه تحقيق
دوليه في اغتيال الشهيد ياسر عرفات على
غرار الشهيد رفيق الحريري ايضا حركه فتح
واللجنه مركزيه لحركه فتح اعلنت بالامس
انها على استعداد للتعاون مع اي فريق
سويسري ياتي الى رام الله من اجل فحص رفاه
الشهيد ياسر عرفات ووضع كل الامكانيات وكل
التسهيلات من اجل الوصول الى الحقيقه كل
كل الشعب الفلسطيني والقياده الفلسطينيه
وكل العالم العربي والاسلامي معني بمعرفه
الحقيقه ولذلك الان الوقت هو وقت جمع ادله
وليس وقت توزيع اتهامات ولا يجوز وقت ضيق
مادام الوقت ضيقا الى هذه الدرجه كما تشير
متى مثلا سينفذ مطلب استخراج عينه من
الروفات حتى يتم فحصها والحصول على دليل
نهائي والذهاب الى تحقيق دولي وتشكيل لجنه
ربما خاصه محكمه خاصه تحاكم المسؤول عن
هذه
الجريمه يعني بالتاكيد سيده غاده نحن
طلبنا من اللجنه الفلسطينيه المكلفه
بالتحقيق الاتصال فورا مع قناه الجزيره
وايضا الاتصال مع الفريق العلمي السويسري
من اجل احضار من اجل احضاره الى تورام
الله واجراء كافه يعني ال كافه الفحوصات
على رفاه الشهيد ياسر عرفات وانا اعتقد
انه كما قال احد اح الاطباء من ادنبرا في
حصاد اليوم او في منتصف اليوم في الجزيره
يكفي من خلال يعني خزعه من العظم او بعض
الاسنان
من صحيح متى ستبدا هذه العمليه هذا السؤال
مت ستبدا هذه العمليه فحص يعني نحن سوف
نطالب السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ببدء
العمليه فورا لانه ن
سكلما تقدم الوقت كلما اختلفت
الادله بالتاكيد
الان مطلوب من لجنه التحقيق القيام ب
بالاتصال مع كل الجهات المعنيه من اجل
احضار الفريق السويسري الى رام الله من
اجل التاكد بشكل قطعي بان رئيس يسر
العرفات قد قضى بفعل السم الشعاعي اللي هو
البولونيوم رقم 2 نامل ان يبدا خلال
الايام القلي القادمه شكرا لك سيد زعتره
اختم معك بما تبقى من هذا الوقت ربما اقل
من دقيقه لو فرضنا ان
انه فحص الرفات وعرف ان عرفات كان مسموما
بشكل نهائي وصلنا الى الحقيقه كيف يمكن
الوصول الى من دس هذا السم وفي حال وصلنا
الى من دس السم كيف يحاكم خاصه انه ربما
يكون
دوله ه هذا هو السؤال الذي يجب ان يطرح
على قياده السلطه الفلسطينيه ما الذي ما
الذي ستفعله اذا ادركت او علمت ان شارون
والكيان الصهيوني هو الذي قتل ياسر عرفات
ياسر عرفات ليس الزعيم الوحيد الذي قتلته
ال اجهزه الصهيونيه هناك زعماء كثر قتلوا
وهؤلاء قتلوا من اجل القضيه الفلسطينيه
وياسر عرفات قتل لانه رفض الخضوع للاملاء
الاسرائيليه واستبدل باخرين كانوا اكثر
طواعيه لتلك الاملاءات هذه المساله مصلحه
القضيه الفلسطينيه هي الاساس وياسر عرفات
استشهد من اجل القضيه الفلسطينيه السؤال
الاساسي هو المسار الذي ستخطط القضيه
الفلسطينيه بعد هذه الجريمه وبعد اكتشاف
هذه الجريمه بل بعد التاكد من هذه الجريمه
يجب ان يكون هناك مراجعه داخل حركه فتح
هؤلاء تحدثوا دائما عن الرمز والشهيد
والمؤسس يجب ان يلتفتوا لاولئك الذين
تامروا عليه والذين انقلبوا عليه والذين
استخدموا من قبل الامريكان والاسرائيليين
ضده هذا هو السؤال الذي يوجه الى قيادات
وكوادر حركه فتح ان يقفوا وقفه صدق امام
انفسهم لكي يحسبوا هؤلاء الذين وفروا
الاجواء المحلل السياسي حدثنا من عمان
ايضا اشكر من القدس حاتم عبد القادر مسؤول
ملف القدس في حركه فتح واشكر دكتور محمد
سلام الخبير في هيئه الرقابه الاشعاعيه
واشكر متابعتكم بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى اللقاء مجددا
باذن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله